there's certain rappers where you feel
like they coin certain things you know
people equate
t-pain and auto-tune like they say that
is his invention what do you feel like
is the thing that the migos invented
the triplet flow for show
yeah the triplet flow when nobody doing
it
before we came and right now everybody's
doing it and
it's a blessing yeah explain the triplet
flow just if people don't know exactly
triple the flow the cadence the um
flipping and whipping it you always want
me to rap
yeah it's working that's a tripoli flow
though so yeah that's what everybody
loved to this day yeah and that's what
you're like people need to equate with
the migos specifically 2014 i was the
most influential rapper you know and
ever since then
sky's the limit for me yeah talk about
why
like you feel like you were holding that
influence specifically at that time
um just just the flow is different the
swag was different um
just some young rich [ __ ] ready to go
i know david banner said i have the
quote i want to make sure i say it right
that he has seen people jack y'all style
jack the way you rap then go on tv and
act like they didn't rip you all off
do you agree with that
yeah most definitely they just don't
want to give credit you don't wanna you
don't wanna come in and say you
you know what i'm saying being new and
saying you took somebody's style or
saying you got the style or don't want
to
say you influenced by too many
young people because you don't know how
people will take it so yeah it's all
good so but why do you think that is
because i know there has has been
different times where you all have
talked about okay like we know this is
ours you know we began this now this
person who maybe at the time had a
bigger platform is doing it and people
are believing that it is their style
like how do you wrestle with kind of
that frustration of knowing that that's
yours only person that can really
um really
pretty much argue about the flow like
who started it or who kind of like
pushed the influences migos and drake
because he came in and got on versace
with us yeah and um
so i feel like that was the first time
in the world i all heard the flow you
know i'm saying when it was migos and
draco on the song so
and
even even with that like even before
that i feel like
nobody else wasn't using nobody else did
it nobody else use it so now when they
come out and say
different people influence and don't say
the amigos i don't understand how yeah
because even the people they naming that
influence them i know for a fact we
influenced them too
have rappers like come up to you and
talked about the influence you've had on
on their sound most definitely yeah most
definitely when has that happened
you just got to keep that to you know to
myself and yeah you know so i don't want
to discredit no artists but
they know i'm the real they know i'm the
realest [ __ ] alive